you
hey youtubers is Charlie so we have
ghostwriter coming to agents of shield
big announcement but we also have
Inhumans royal family so I'm going to do
a breakdown of what's going on all the
stuff they announced to Comic Con so the
big tease here is that Ghost Rider is
coming to agents of shield people
actually believe this for a while so it
turns out the rumors true it's really
cool and if you wonder why that is like
why they can do a big movie character
it's because Marvel controls the rights
now like they have the rights to do a
Ghost Rider movie but because of the
tone of the movies right now and the
things that they're wanting to do
there's just no plans to do a Ghost
Rider movie anytime soon Marvel Studios
so the character is just sitting on the
shelf so he's free for the TV show to
use but the TV show is not doing the
Ghost Rider that most of you are
familiar with most of you know about the
Johnny Blaze Ghost Rider he's the
original version of the character he's
the one that rides the motorcycle he's
the one all those terrible movies are
based on so the one they're doing on the
TV show is the latest Ghost Rider in the
comics so the current version of the
character is called Ravi Reyes so that
sounds very much like the Mexican
American character that agents of shield
is doing who in a roundabout way they've
kind of been teasing as a supernatural
connection to the Marvel Universe a lot
of people felt like that meant that they
were doing ghost riders so they dropped
this at comic-con a light bulb goes on
and everyone's like all right they're
doing the thing it's gonna be a lot of
fun but this version of Ghost Rider
drives a car so when he activates his
powers the whole car goes up in flames
instead of just like the flaming
motorcycle I'm interested to see how
they do the effects on the TV show
because it gets really expensive when
you have to do special effects for a
character that's in like every single
frame so expect a lot of creative
reasons for why he walks around not
looking like Ghost Rider most of the
time they haven't said whether or not
they're gonna do his origin story from
the comics but it's pretty straight up
it'd be pretty easy for them to do it so
if you've never read this version of
Ghost Rider he's just a normal person
living in East Los Angeles who's visited
by the spirit of his uncle who says I
was killed by gang members please avenge
me so he becomes this Ghost Rider
character but then later he finds out
that his uncle is actually this really
terrible satanic killer who killed all
these people heard a bunch of people in
his family so it becomes this big battle
for his body where you have like the
evil spirit that wants to murder more
people trying to take control of his
conscious mind so he makes this deal and
says okay
you want to kill people I'll kill people
if you let me stay in control of my body
but I'm only going to kill evil people
so we'll see how they deal with that on
the TV show but on top of all that like
separately from this big Ghost Rider
announcement Joss Whedon has talked
about doing classic Inhumans because
they're just there aren't any big plans
to do an Inhumans movie anytime soon so
he made comments like I'm paraphrasing
here but he made comments to the effect
that they're going to have access to
some very classic Inhumans so
tongue-in-cheek you're talking about the
royal family follow a question I know
you're all asking now does that mean
that they're going to do Black Bolt on
the TV show well you know once you say
royal family it's almost like anyone's
up for grabs so that is not the case
just because they can do classic
characters doesn't mean they have access
to the entire royal family one of the
biggest ones they could probably get
away with without stepping on any of the
toes of movie plans that might be
happening behind the scenes is Karnak
Karnak is a huge character that's a
member of the royal family but isn't
like Captain America Iron Man Thor level
big so just remains to be seen about
which of those classic Inhumans they end
up doing but the way he made it sound
you know because they have life model
decoy stuff happening this season now
they have Ghost Rider they have a new
director of shield who's being played by
Jason O'Mara who a lot of you guys
remember from the DC animated movies I
think this means that the classic
Inhumans stuff that Joss Whedon was
teasing will start happening much much
later this season so I'm not gonna hold
my breath for classic Inhumans but if
they're saying that they have access to
them just expect some of the big arcs
this season like the big storylines to
lead to royal family at tulle and things
if you're wondering about TV actors or
TV storylines crossing over with the
movies don't you know don't hold your
breath on that the Netflix defenders
characters have a slightly better chance
and even the people associated with that
or sent you know like you know probably
not going to be crossing over with the
movies anytime soon relatively
self-contained storyline even though
that's turning into a relatively big
thing it's just that the tone of like
the Netflix stuff is so different from
the tone of the movies that it doesn't
blend really well like it would be so
gimmicky if they were to try to include
them in the movies but I always do get a
lot of questions about whether or not
the TV actors or the TV storylines are
going to crossover with the movies but
here's a big question for you guys do
you want to see agents of shield
crossover with the net
series because a lot of people remember
the Jeph Loeb made Clark Gregg a promise
that he would be able to guess star in
his favorite characters series of all
time so in real life Clark Griggs
favorite Marvel character of all time is
Danny Rand iron fist so when people
asked them hate you know is Phil Coulson
gonna be the person to put the defenders
together well I think that last year or
maybe even two years ago Jeff lobe who's
the president of Marvel TV who kind of
oversees all this stuff he's like the
Kevin Feige of the TV shows he said I
made Clark Gregg a promise now he didn't
say exactly what that is but I think
that means the Clark Gregg will get a
cameo in Iron Fist somewhere but no idea
what that's going to look like or
whether or not that's going to come to
fruition but let me know do you think
the Coulson is going to appear an iron
fist or the defenders there's a much
better chance of that happening than any
of those characters appearing in the
movies
so because of all this shield news I
just pushed my Black Panther video
tonight so I'll be doing a Black Panther
movie video they announced a whole bunch
of stuff about the characters at Comic
Con it's really exciting but they
haven't started shooting it yet
so there's no footage or anything like
that but they did reveal a whole bunch
of stuff about the movie so I'll be
posting that later tonight so be sure to
subscribe to get that but in slightly
related news too I'm getting to see
Suicide Squad early this week so I'll
see it on Tuesday I'll post a
non-spoilery review early then like
normal I'll wait a couple days and post
my Easter Egg video so be sure and go
see it this week both DC and Marvel are
doing way more supernatural stuff in the
movies now it's going to be really
exciting where you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for my
breakdown to the spider-man homecoming
footage and you can click here for my
breakdown of the guardians of the galaxy
2 trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight